[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in harold reynolds who's
joining us major league baseball network
analyst game one of the alcs red sox and
astros begins tonight on fox you can
watch harold before and after every game
on mlb networks mlb tonight all right
let's start with the check swing
give me what is the ruling on the check
swing and what did you think about the
call
well i didn't think it was a good call i
think he missed it um the ruling though
is that's non-reviewable
and we've come across a few plays in
baseball where
they don't get reviewed which i think at
this point in time
reviews should be for everything out
there because you don't have
conversations like this
and so
uh i know they continue to grow and
change we'll see if that happens with
this but how do you review it is it the
umpires review it or do i have to have a
challenge flag to do this is there an
eye in the sky that helps these umpires
and says you guys need to check this a
home office like you have with the nfl
well most reviews are come out in new
york anyway um
in pace of the game you may have to have
somebody designated at the stadium you
can't take three minutes in the middle
of an at-bat to call put your headset on
okay he didn't go
now your picture's iced the hitter is
different than any other sport so you
got to keep it moving and one of the
things they've done dan real quick with
replay
is you know managers got 20 seconds to
challenge something on the field and
then they gotta then they can start the
process but i think we got to make it
more like real time not oh i saw
something now i review it uh that's not
right either the dodgers advanced
because
depth i mean we saw it all who can go
get max scherzer who can take a 20-game
winner and say ah you know what we're
going to start with an opener i mean the
depth of this team is
so deep so i think that's why they will
continue to to go through now seven
games really shows the depth of this
club
mookie betts once again like mookie bets
sometimes you forget
and then mookie batch taps you on the
shoulder and says don't forget
like how good is mookie betts
he's one of the greats of all time i
mean he does something every game the
other night he made the spin around
throw and said oh my that's brother
clemente you know last night he gets
four hits
um i really think him playing in boston
and that pressure cooker as a young
player
helped him slow the game down and
understand the moments watching him do
pregame interviews yesterday
he acted as if it was a regular season
game that only comes with experience
but i go back to the red sox when they
got rid of it
did they make the right move i mean here
they are in the alcs
they saved a lot of money was it the
right move for the red sox
well i think the red sox kind of wanted
to
save him and lock him up i mean they
offered him a pretty good deal but i
think mookie really wanted to go um at
the end of the day
as we look back now what three years
removed that was more mookie's decision
than the red sox i think he wanted to go
somewhere else
scherzer coming out of the bullpen like
i don't think he came charging out of
the bullpen he it was like you know the
the running of the bulls in pomplona i
mean it was he wanted to get on that
mound it was almost like he was being
timed like hey if you don't get there in
15 seconds then you don't get to pitch
but man i love watching him pitch
it's so great
in our sport to see a guy go i want the
ball yeah you know in football it's
different basketball because you you
have to go to the go-to guy
and in baseball you know he's going on
two days rest we we have regiments we
have schedules he came ready to play and
i just love him i gotta tell you this
quick story dad i was shooting this
thing with him
three years ago for nike it was a whole
new nike ad they were coming out with
new equipment and so i spent time with
with trout springer
baez and scherzer went to eat spring
training camp so max is in full gear
they're breaking up the new nike uniform
it's not out yet so he's got to throw a
bullpen that day and we're like hey can
we film you live
no problem so we watch his bullpen he's
got a simulated game he's going to throw
two in a simulated game he has full
union
you'll love this damn he throws
16 20 pitches and now he's getting ready
to go play the simulator game he stops
after the 15th pitch takes his hat off
and is standing there singing the anthem
set so i'm i'm like well shoot i guess i
better take my hat off and stand here
too he's singing through the anthem he
the pitching coach and the catcher they
all stop and as soon as they finish the
full complete anthem he put his hat back
on grabbed the rosin got the ball
through five more pitches and spread it
to the mound i want this guy's nuts
he's a gamer
but
he's got 197
wins including the post season but a
hall of famer right oh yeah no doubt
first ballot i i think also dan we got
to start looking hall of fame different
with this generation yeah yeah i was
going to ask you that game has flipped
it's totally flipped in the last 10
years and particularly the last five
years we may never see a guy throw 200
innings in a season i mean how are we
going to gauge 300 wins so
um it is totally different now we got to
start looking at how we're going to look
at guys for hall of fame i'd throw this
to you real quick
and think about this you and mcmu
mclovin and all the guys there this may
be the best contract in sports history
for baseball for sure the contract he
had with washington he fulfilled it
pitched every start
won a world series
all-star two cy youngs in there it's
pretty impressive
well i also wonder about jacob degrom
he might go into the hall of fame as a
500 pitcher
i know man
look it's gone when felix hernandez won
the cy young i think in seattle one year
is 13 and 12 and then well but look at
this whip and look at all these other
numbers
it was it was over game over like degrom
was ten and nine
and they were trying to give him the mvp
i'm out
uh we're talking to harold reynolds of a
major league baseball network
um
altuve is
still raking man i i i know it's hard to
leave 2017 in the rear view mirror here
i don't know can you leave 2017 in the
rearview mirror when you talk about
today's astros
no you can't uh the core of that club is
still there and even if you
weren't on that team you were now
banging on a garbage can i mean that's
just the way you're going to be viewed
and
i wouldn't even bring it up if the
players weren't answering that question
themselves they know it that's just
going to be with them forever
i do i do remember back then when it
first broke in like 19 or whatever that
altuve was the one player that everybody
was saying he didn't want signs
and i i get that i played with the
number of players who never wanted signs
uh they wanted they would give signs but
they didn't want to know what might be
coming in case you messed up giving it
to them
so when you're at second base and you're
signaling in whether it's location or
well it's probably location that you're
signaling in aren't you
sometimes both depending on if you can
pick up
the pictures signs and everything else
so yeah but i i located i located and
recognized both i sent both in okay who
did you take advantage of
picture-wise
oh
um
i don't know about pitcher it's more
catchers that would get lazy okay who
did you take advantage of the sign they
go through one round and then they're
throwing just a simple one down like
pudge rodriguez was a guy used to do
that he'd just go through the signs and
get frustrated go all right fast
okay
basketball in yeah
but what would you do in real time so
you're at second base you're leading off
second base
yeah and what's this
so real time i would go to my helmet i'd
walk back to the base step on the base
go to my helmet like this like i'm
adjusting it not let the hitter know i
have the signs
so
being the lead off guy i would try to
get there and see sequences and if
you're i was able to figure it out i may
talk to somebody else who got there by
the fourth or fifth inning if that's
same pitchers out there and catcher we
had their signs
and
so guys came up with a lot of different
creative things when i was with seattle
and mark langston was pitching his signs
were so complicated i still don't know
how the other infielders even knew a lot
of times i didn't know but what he did
was he played what they called the
scoreboard sign one and one
two two oh oh any even count was first
sign
so o first sign so let's say he throws a
strike now he's one he's on one it would
be the third sign and then if it was one
to know it would be the same so odd
number then it goes back two one one two
you want a different second sign so it
was a trip you had to really follow
along did you ever give ken griffey jr a
sign from second base
no ken griffey jr
uh are we are we destined for
astros dodgers
i sure hope so
i mean i want to see alex cora face joe
kelly hit a ball and blow him a kiss i
mean i i'm looking forward to seeing
this and i think the fans want it you
know in la they've been they've been
wanting this matchup i think it'll be
great for the sport always great to
catch up with you thanks as always hr
all right my friend take care dp harold
reynolds mlb network analyst and uh game
one of the alcs red sox astros tonight
on fox you can watch harold before and
after every game mlb network mlb
tonight